- We're featuring my interview
ocean voyager Nainoa Thompson.
And I had to ask him how the
ancient Polynesians navigated
2,400 miles from Hawaii
to Tahiti without being
able to calculate longitude.
Let's check it out.
OK, imagine, imagine.
You're standing on
the beach at Waikiki.
You're looking over the
horizon to where Tahiti is.
And now imagine you draw
one line like an arc
to the west side of
Tahiti and the other line
to the east side.
That's your target.
It's less than a degree.
So your destination is
not in view, because it's
far beyond your horizon.
Over the horizon.
So your destination
spans an angle
from where you are standing.
In Waikiki.
And as long as you
navigate inside that angle,
nothing else matters.
- Right.
Because you're going to get to
your target on the other side.
Really, really smart.
Wait, wait.
In fact, it seems to me your
angle can be wider than that
because you just have
to get your destination
within your horizon, and then
you can just dead reckon to it.
Right, 15 miles east or west.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, 15 miles.
So you have a 30
mile, so it's really
the width of 30
miles at the distance
of where you're headed.
Right.
That's your angle.
2,400 miles away though.
So right, so that's 30.
So that's narrow, but
still it's a known problem.
Right.
Yes.
But there's so many
unknowns in the navigation
that it's not a GPS.
It's not a coordinate system.
You don't have longitude.
You need instruments
and you need
tables, which we don't have.
It's a dead reckoning system.
So you only know where
you are by memorizing
where you come from.
If you memorize
where you come from,
that meant you've
got to be awake.
You know, we stay up
21, 22 hours a day.
So it ain't easy.
Here's what you do.
Slip this in your coat.
Don't tell anybody, OK.
So that's that same
sextant, by the way.
I see he didn't take it.
No, he didn't take it.
No, no, no.
He doesn't need it,
that's the whole point.
Yeah, thank you.
He's like, I got this.